millions of people meanwhile bracing
hoping for a different kind of luck
bracing for a potentially massive
flooding as tropical storm
Harvey gains strength in the Gulf of
Mexico hurricane warning was issued
overnight from much of the Texas coast
harvey is expected to become a hurricane
tomorrow before making landfall sometime
tomorrow night or Saturday morning and
some places could see more than two feet
of rain Randy Smith of our Houston
affiliate KHOU is watching the storm
from Galveston and as the latest brandy
good morning good morning city officials
have already started hauling off
lifeguard towers that used to be on the
beach here in Galveston you can see the
tracks from the bulldozers as those
please move the towers inland the city
isn't taking any chances as this could
be the biggest storm to hit the area
since Hurricane Ike in 2008 now Texas
governor Greg Abbott already issued a
state of emergency in 30 counties
emergency officials have also asked
people on the upper coastline to move or
prepare to move inland but state
officials have not yet made any
evacuation orders people have already
started filling sandbags to protect
their homes and businesses and crews
began tying up some of the more than 650
boats at the marina here and people are
also watching the storm surge that could
get up to 4 feet here so of course
everyone is going to be watching the
forecast very closely over the next
couple of days gale you're right about
that thank you brandy